The answer that you get when you us this formula is 0.417.
So 0.417 is the new value of the feature that belongs to the 140 pound person.
So the way we did this is we take our x min and x max.
We plug them into the formula.
And we plug in the 140 as well in the position for the sort of old value of x.
And from that we can compute x prime.
And one of the features of this formula for rescaling features is
that your transform features will always be between 0 and 1.
Now this has some benefits and some disadvantages.
One of the benefits is you have a very reliable number as to what you
can expect in the output.
One of the disadvantages is that if you have outliers in your input
features then they can kind of mess up your rescaling because your x min and
your x max might have really extreme values.
So now what I want to do is I want to give you a programming quiz.
Where I have you actually program this up yourself.